ses rizières sont presque vides ce matin
en cause la très forte hausse du prix de
l'engrais qui étouffent l'économie
agricole nigérienne le sac d'urée
engrais le plus utilisé au niger est
passé de 18 heures au début 2000 21 à 34
euros en 2022
à cause du prix très cher de l'engrais
je ne peux pas employer plus de
personnes sur cette parcelle
il devrait avoir beaucoup de gens mais
tout l'argent va dans l'achat d'engrais
ici au moins six personnes devraient
travailler
pas seulement de
cet engrais a récemment vu son prix
exploser une nouvelle fois de près de
30%
conséquence directe de la guerre en
ukraine le prix du gaz russe composant
indispensable de l'engrais a fortement
augmenté
en plus de la guerre en ukraine le
secteur agricole subit les effets de la
sécheresse et de l'insécurité dans le
pays qui rendent les récoltes plus
irrégulière
le gouvernement a décidé fin mars de
réduire les taxes sur certaines denrées
comme le mil 17 % plus cher cette année
qu'à la même période en 2021 amap taxo
ce n'est pas les taxes ce qui font que
le mil le sorgho ou le maïs deviennent
chères
ne va pas changer grand chose puisque
c'est nous mêmes qui les cultivent
encore
les récoltes de 2021 ont eu un rendement
inférieur de 39% par rapport à la
moyenne des cinq dernières années au
niger un manque énorme de denrées qui
pourrait mener à la pire crise
alimentaire qu'a connues le pays depuis
dix ans trois millions et demi de
personnes seraient alors toucher d'ici
juin 2022